- [Voiceover] So what we're
going to do in this video
is look at a series of
vectors, and we're gonna
draw them in standard form,
where their initial points
or their tails are
gonna sit at the origin.
And we're gonna see if we can figure out
the angles that they
form, the positive angles
that they form with the positive x-axis.
And like always, pause this video and see
if you could figure out
what these thetas are
going to be on your own, and we're gonna
figure 'em out in degrees.
So in this first one, I have the vector u.
If we were to write it
in unit-vector notation,
sometimes this is called
engineering notation,
we would say it's three
times the unit vector
in the horizontal direction,
the i unit vector,
plus four times the unit vector
in the vertical direction
or you could view this as
the x-component is three
and the y-component is
four, and you see that here.
If you start at the origin,
we're gonna move three
in the horizontal direction,
and we're gonna move
four in the vertical direction.
Now to figure out this theta, there's
a couple of ways to think about it.
We could just construct a right triangle
for this one in particular.
We could say, okay, the
x-coordinate is three.
So if we were to create
a right triangle here,
this side would have a length of three,
and then we have a height of four
or the y-coordinate is four.
So this side has a length of four,
and we know just from
even our basic SOHCAHTOA
definitions of trig functions
that what trig function
involves the opposite of an angle?
So the opposite of an angle,
and the adjacent of an angle?
Well, tangent does.
SOHCAHTOA.
So we know, we know that
the tangent of theta
is going to be equal to the
length of the opposite side,
which is four, over the length of
the adjacent side, over three.
And so if we wanted to solve for theta,
we could just say that theta is equal to
the inverse tangent.
Sometimes people say arc tangent
of 4/3, of four over ...
four over three, and let's evaluate this.
And I'm gonna get my
calculator out to do it.
So I wanna take four divided by three,
which is that, and I
had already had pressed
this button right over here that takes my
tangent and makes it
into an inverse tangent.
So I'm gonna take the
inverse tangent of this,
and I get, I get roughly 53.1 degrees.
So this is approximately
53.1 degrees, which looks about right.
This looks like a little
bit more, even though
I didn't draw it
completely super precisely.
I hand-drew this.
It looks a little bit more
than a 45 degree angle,
so that feels, that feels pretty good.
Now another thing you might have said,
"Hey. Well, look.
"Four is the y-component.
"Three is the x-component,
and so maybe tangent
"of theta is always going to be
"the y-component over the x-component."
And that, in fact, is the case.
And that actually comes
straight out of the
unit circle definition
of the trig functions,
where you could say that if you have
a unit circle, if you have, I
could draw it right over here.
So let me draw the coordinates.
So if I were to draw a unit
circle right over here,
and if I were to have some line,
here we're thinking about vectors,
that the angle formed
with the positive x-axis,
the tangent of that
angle, tangent of theta
is going to be the y-coordinate, where we
intersect the circle,
over the x-coordinate.
And so you could imagine if you made
a unit circle right here,
if you made a unit circle
right over here, the ratio
between the y-coordinate
and the x-coordinate of
this point right over here
where we intersect the
circle is going to be
the same thing as the ratio
between four and three.
So this is going to be,
this also is going to be
one and 1/3 or 4/3.
So either way, you could
think of, when you think of
vectors, the tangent of
the angle that it forms
with the positive x-axis is going to be,
is going to be the y-component
over the x-component.
So it's nice when everything
kinda fits together like that.
So let's leverage that to figure out
this, to figure out this
angle right over there.
Well, we could say that tangent of theta
is going to be equal to the y-component.
The y-component over the x-component.
Over, do this in a new color
or let's see, over negative five.
So it's gonna be negative 6/5.
Or we could say theta.
So let's be a little bit careful.
So we could say, we could say that theta
is equal to, is equal
to the inverse tangent.
Let me do that same color.
Inverse tangent of, I'll
just write it like this,
negative 6/5, but I'm going
to put a little question mark
here to see if we feel
good about the answer
that you get when we do this.
So let's do that.
So if we do, if we do six divided by five,
which'll equal to that, and then we
want to make this negative.
So that's negative 6/5, and we're gonna
take the inverse tangents.
I already pressed this button, so this
is going to be an inverse
tangent, not tangent.
I get negative, roughly
negative 50.2 degrees.
So this is approximately
Well, does that look right?
Well, no.
Theta looks like it's over 90 degrees.
Negative 50.2 degrees,
negative 50.2 degrees
is actually giving us this
angle right over here.
So that's giving us, that's specifying
another vector, if you think about a line,
another line that would
have the same tangent.
The same tangent.
So it's really important to visualize this
and think about this,
and the reason why it is
is because the arc tangent or
the inverse tangent functions
in calculators, they
will give you an angle
that is between negative 90 degrees and
positive 90 degrees, so something
that's in the fourth or first quadrant.
While here, we have something
that's in the second quadrant.
So we have to make sure that
we're thinking about it right
so that we could make the
appropriate adjustment.
So that would give the
case if we were looking
at a line like that or a vector like that.
So in order to figure out
what, in order to figure out
the actual angle, what we want to do
is add 180 degrees to it.
So to get the vector that
goes in the other direction.
So you want to add, so theta
is going to be equal to
or I could say approximately equal to
negative 50.2 degrees plus 180 degrees.
So let's do that.
So let me plus 180 is equal to
approximately 129.8 degrees.
So theta is approximately
equal to 129.8 degrees.
Did I get that right?
I have a very short memory.
Okay, yeah; that's right.
129.8 degrees, and that looks much better.
That looks clearly is
an angle we're gonna go.
That take us to 90 degrees,
and then we're going above 90 degrees.
Now another way you could
have thought about this
is what you know from SOHCATOA
and just right triangles.
We could construct a right triangle where,
we construct a right
triangle using some colors.
Well, we know, so I could
maybe just draw it like this.
So this is the height of
it, and what is that height?
Well, the height is going to be six,
and then the base, the
base right over here,
what is that length going to be?
Well, we know that we're
going from the origin,
we're going five back, but
if we think about just the
absolute value, the length of that line,
that is going to be five, and so we could
figure out just using
right triangles this angle.
Maybe we call that x, and so we could say
that the tangent of x, tangent of x
is equal to six over five,
opposite over adjacent.
Six over five.
Or that x, or you could say
x is equal to the inverse tangent
of 6/5, and what is that going to be?
So, if we take six divided by five, 1.2.
And then we're going to take
the inverse tangent of that,
and we get approximately 50.2 degrees.
So x is approximately 50.2 degrees,
which looks right.
But remember, we're not
trying to figure out x,
we're trying to figure out,
we are trying to figure out what theta,
what theta is, and you
can see that x and theta
are supplementary.
So theta plus x is going to be 180 or
theta's gonna be 180 minus that.
So 180 minus that.
So let's just put a negative
sign in front of that
and add 180, and that might look familiar.
So that gets to us to
129, roughly 129.8 degrees
is what exactly what we got before.